another contender for the Labour
leadership has emerged on Smith Welsh MP
who used to hold the shadow Work and
Pensions brief of course he's thrown his
hat into the ring now that's head of
what promises to be a very big week for
the party with the votes on the Trident
nuclear deterrent that's tomorrow well
let's speak now to Hilary bandy former
shadow foreign secretary who's sacking
by Jeremy Corbyn seems to have started
all this spark those masks resignation
from the Shadow Cabinet and here we are
now why are you going for that good
morning why aren't you going for the
leadership look good morning you know
I'm not and I'm backing Angela Eagle
because I think she's got integrity I
think she's got a huge amount of
experience but above all she's
demonstrated extraordinary courage in
the last few weeks she has stood up and
said I'm going to challenge Jeremy
called them for the leadership because
we desperately need new leadership of
the party we have an unprecedented
situation Dermot in which eighty percent
of labour and pieces said we don't have
confidence in our lead and it's
impossible to see how Jeremy Corbyn
could take us into a general election in
that situation but the decision now
rests in the hands of party members and
I'm sure they'll think long and hard
about the vote that they cast when the
ballot papers go out I'd say we've got
Owen Smith now joining the fray we knew
that perfect for quite a while but he's
confirming it would you say I mean an
allen Smith has said it himself but it
would be better that one challenger took
on Jeremy Corbyn would you agree with
that and said back at you own Smith well
I think that would be preferable and
that's why I'm backing Angela because I
think she is the person who should be
challenging Jeremy and she came out
first stood first Owen has many
qualities he'd also make a great leader
but we have to see what decision the
parliamentary Labour Party makes we have
the hustings tomorrow but it's also not
just about that because constituency
Labour Party's also have the opportunity
to make supporting nominations and that
will give an indication of the Rangers
port out in the country before the
ballot but just all those hustings allen
Smith seems to be indicating well
whoever's got the most sport out of that
they should be the one the sole
challenger to Jeremy Corbyn it goes
forward would you accept that well I
wouldn't because what I what I was
saying to you is it's not just about the
decision that the parliamentary Labour
Party makes although of course that's
hugely
the party out there has a chance to make
supporting nominations and we should
test the water there they'll no doubt be
a lot of nominations for Jeremy but
there will also be nominations from
constituencies for others and I hope
that Angela gets a lot of nominations
and then people can make their own judge
we've got my son laughs yeah yeah but I
thought constituency businesses being
suspended by a McNichol partly because
of all the abuse that's going on it has
except for the purposes of a central
business to do with lemon party
conference and the making of the
nominations but you're right the Labor
Party is in a pretty unhappy state and I
think whatever was the kind of death
talking about violence and intimidation
that meet some of these must be a bear
pit it's really very difficult and it's
distressing because you know for all of
us who've devoted our lives to the Labor
Party being members a long time the sort
of abuse that is being directed at
ordinary Labour Party members whatever
the idea was behind a kinder gentler
politics it's not what we have seen and
I'm sorry that some of those and it is a
minority but some of those who are
supporting Jeremy seem to think it is
acceptable to abuse parliamentary
colleagues particularly women members of
the PLP and others if you don't support
Jeremy then you get all sorts of abuse
and we cannot be a party like that and
not only do we have to call it out but
we need a new leader so we can heal what
is clearly a very divided party so what
happens everyone is saying the same
thing including jeremy corbyn that once
the result is in whoever it may be we've
got to unite behind that leader do you
go along with that even if it is jeremy
corbyn well we need to see what the
result is but I think for Labor members
of parliament who have said I'm afraid
we don't have confidence in your
leadership I suspect people will
continue to hold that view because it
look I served in his shadow
accommodation people are going to that
hesitation Hilary Benn people are going
to say is he nearly going to say the S
word are you thinking of a split if
Jeremy Corbyn no absolutely not let's be
very clear about this is idle talk in
some newspapers I've been a member of
the Labour Party for 45 years I intend
to die in the labour party but not for
many years yet and we are passionate
about the values and beliefs of our
party and we are staying
and we're not going anywhere and in the
end this problem will eventually be
sorted out but the fundamental
difficulty is we have a leader who
cannot command the confidence of those
he's meant to lead in Parliament and
there's two parts to the job you are the
leader of the members that's true but
you also have to lead the people in
Parliament and that is clean and they're
waiting in there and then we see that
very divided in the house of commons on
the issue of things like trident whereas
you've got free vote now Labour MPs and
majority of you going to go yes we want
to renew the system and your leader
wants to get rid of it well jeremy has
long held of you and I admire and
respect his principles I disagree with
him because I think the first duty of
government and indeed of a party that
aspires to be in government is to defend
the nation and I want to see a world as
he does with no nuclear weapons the
issue has always been how do you get
there and Britain giving up ours alone
would not persuade any of the other
nuclear States to do it who knows what
the threats will be in 20-30 years time
nuclear deterrence has helped to keep
the peace because it says to any
potential aggressor and what are we
talking about here preventing an attack
on our country having the nuclear
deterrence says to them I really
wouldn't think about it if I really has
droids anybody want to live in a world
don't in which nobody had nuclear
weapons accept North Korea well I
wouldn't feel safe a mad world and I
suspect nor would you okay well if
illustrates the wider point though
doesn't it Jeremy Corbyn is returned
these things will just reoccur and
reoccur and reoccur again the majority
of am peas going one direction but being
prisoners then of the leader who they
kind of United around it won't split the
party you remain as an ineffective
opposition and then get smashed apart in
another general election well that is
why Angela went out in front and said
I'm going to challenge Jeremy because
this situation cannot continue and we
need a strong and effective opposition
particularly at a time of great
challenge for the country the
consequences of breck see what's
happening around the world what happened
in in in Turkey on Friday night we need
an effective opposition and if we aren't
effective then the communities that we
represent the people who support we wish
to win will face continuation of what is
a right-wing conservative just last
question again the one I started with
Hillary venue you won't reconsider not
not standing
when you resign people were thinking
okay or sorry when you were sacked we
thinking of well Hilary Benn would be
very good leader of this part I'm not
and I didn't take the decision that I
did to say to Jeremy I no longer had
confidence him because I wish to lead
the Labour Party I told him that because
I believed it to be true and I think you
have to be straight and honest about
these things Hilary been good to see you
thank you very much an easier time